[Music]
Hey
pardon me sir I think you have the wrong
car you've emailed for an appointment
two days in a row tell me what's going
on I've never seen a case like this
before
23 identities live in Kevin's body
did something happened there's a flower
on the pillows a fire in the bathroom
like we're important who is that maybe
she can help us don't worry he knows
what you're here for
he's not allowed to touch you he knows
that my name is Hedwig I have read facts
oh nice the human brain is the most
complex object in the universe we're
getting out of here sighs aren't you the
clever one Harry could you help us okay
I have the window in my room maybe you
could show us that's here now it's
closed now it's open
so you could leave
an individual with multiple
personalities can change their body
chemistry with their thoughts someone's
coming for you what will happen when he
unlocks the potential of his brain there
is no limit to what he can become
tonight is a sacred night you will be in
the presence of something greater the
world will understand now the Beast is
real
he's done awful things to people and
he'll do awful things to you
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
pardon me sir I think you have the wrong
car
[Music]
what are we doing here what the hell is
going on I was sent to get you for a
reason
ah there was a flower on the pillows a
flower in the bathroom like we're
important the only chance we have is if
all three of us go crazy on this guy who
is that maybe she can help us don't
worry he's not allowed to touch him he
knows what you're here for
listens to me
my name is Hedwig
nein I've never seen a case like this
before
23 identities live in Kevin's body
who are you help me get out of your head
where you trying to trick me I'll tell
on you
aren't you the clever ones
an individual with multiple
personalities can change their body
chemistry with their thoughts someone's
coming for you who's coming the Beast
there's a man here he ducked at us and
he's going to kill me
we're meant for something something our
hope
[Music]
the world will understand now
the Beast is real he's done awful things
to people and he'll do awful things to
you
[Music]
you